les 12-14 info sud radio le face à face
des éditorialistes bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez dans le 12 14 infosud
radio c'est lors du face à face des
éditorialistes nous sommes ce mercredi
avec marc fesneau secrétaire général du
modem et robin rivaton économistes
essayiste auteur de la france est prête
nous avons déjà changé aux éditions des
lettres bonjour messieurs bonjour
bonjour on va d'abord parlé de
l'agression de ses militaires à nice
hier après midi trois militaires agressé
au couteau ils ont pu quitter l'hôpital
on sait que le suspect moussa coulibaly
qui est en garde à vue et étaient connus
pour prosélytisme agressif notamment
dans une salle de sport qu'il avait été
refoulée ya il ya quelques jours de
turquie marc raynaud est sain un manque
de surveillance de béton le neutraliser
dès son retour en france
la difficulté de ce genre de d'individus
c'est qu'on est face à des individus
dont on suppose les intentions mais tant
qu'on n'est pas dans des faits avérés
c'est difficile d'agir d'un point de vue
juridique il ya quand même quelque chose
qui a fonctionné c'est que les services
français ont prévenu les services turc
de l'arrivée de ce ressortissant
français et on le refoulé renvoyés en
france
ça pose d'ailleurs me semble-t-il une
question plus lourde c'est qu'est ce
qu'on va faire de ceux qui sont partis
en irak et en syrie
mené ce qu'ils appellent le jihad parce
qu'ils reviendront pour ceux qui
reviendront vivant et donc ils sont
citoyens français qu'est ce qu'on fait
ces gens là et deuxièmement quand on a
des gens qui sont dans un processus de
départ comment on arrive à faire en
sorte en amont de débrancher si je peux
dire la façon qu'ils ont d'aborder le
monde et donc me semble-t-il ça nous
pose un problème au delà de le mécanisme
at il bien fonctionné pour moi il a pas
mal fonctionné en l'occurrence le
problème c'est qu'après comment on
arrive à surveiller on nous dit que
c'est un millier de milliers trois
milliers d'individus comme on arrive à
surveiller est ce qu'on fait de ces
personnes dangereuses
ils sont supposés dangereux ils sont
potentiellement dangereux on sait qu'ils
peuvent passer à l'acte mais à quel
moment on arrive à parler voie
judiciaire à faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent pas passer à l'acte en tout cas
la surveillance doit être renforcée et
ça prouve que on a besoin d'avoir un
dispositif de sécurité très fort parce
que s'il n'y avait pas eu les trois
militaires on ne sait pas ce qu aurait
fait ce monsieur avec son couteau
rob arrive à temps oui oui je pense que
le dispositif a plutôt bien fonctionné
faut quand même
s'ils saluent et quand ça marche pas
trop mal cette personne s'est
radicalisée du président prosélytisme
agressif qu'il n'a pas non plus fait une
agression avant il a pas eu besoin des
signes avant coureurs très dangereux il
avait pas non plus acheter d'armes
munitions donc après les forces de
police ont fait leur maximum ils ont
signalé aux autorités turques qui l'ont
refoulé à l'aéroport à l'arrêt
portuaires dans lequel il est dans
lequel il est arrivé il a été entendu
par là des séries quand il est revenu en
france
ils ont jugé que les signes qui avait le
son dossier qui était quand même
relativement fin pour le coup ne
méritait pas le début une enquête et
c'est normal des séries doit se
concentrer sur l'a10 les plus dangereux
et on sait que nadal du chi qui sont
armés qui préparent des plans beaucoup
plus sérieux que celui-ci est donc ils
l'ont laissée avec qui la ville a une
fiche il était sous surveillance n'est
pas une surveillance très très forte
et puis il est passé à l'acte
directement directement après
effectivement le fait qu'il est il n'a
pas voulu agresser des militaires comme
on a tendance à dire il a une agression
de militaire il a voulu agresser en fait
le lieu de culte juif qui avait il a
trouvé devant lui des militaires et puis
finalement les militaires sont sont
posés à lui assez assez facilement
puisqu'ils n'étaient pas armés lui-même
avait des couteaux donc c'était pas
heureusement qu'il n'est pas du matériel
d'art met donc la d euros ciments
français a plutôt fait du bon travail je
veux dire on n'est pas sur un individu
qui était très lourdement armé qui était
très menaçant peut-on imaginer
d'incarcérer ces personnes supposées
dangereuse avant qu'elles passent à
l'acte c'est difficile évidemment c'est
difficile d'un point de vue juridique
d'un car c'est avec quelqu'un sur le
sait comme vous prenez le cas d'un
gangster quelqu'un qui veut faire un vol
à main armée vous le surveillez-vous
l'attraper au moment où il part pour
aller faire son acte oui tant qu'il a
dans la tête simplement et qui n'a pas
bougé c'est quand même difficile sur la
sur des projets j'ajoute un dernier mot
quand même là dessus pour moi qui est
important c'est qu'on est quand même là
aussi sur des individus de même nature
c'est-à-dire des quelqu'un qui était
fiché a effectivement parlé des séries
comme un individu potentiellement arts à
surveiller et deuxièmement c'est qu'il
était quand même passé par toutes les
cases de violence violences volontaires
outrages à agents c'est quand même des
gens qui donnent était déjà des
délinquants alors de nombreux politiques
disent aussi que on pourrait envisager
pour les personnes qui sont partis se
former au jihad en syrie où
ailleurs de les empêcher de revenir en
france ou de carrément de leur retirer
la nationalité française
est-ce que c'est envisageable ça robin
rivaton alors je sais pas si ces
personnes avaient une double nationalité
mais s'il se défend aussi la seule
nationalité française mais entend
toujours ce même problème mais une
partie à une grande partie de ces gens
là qui ont seulement à la société
française donc on peut l'être dès
déchoir dans la société française ça ne
changerait en fait qu' ils doivent
brésil doivent rester sur le théâtre
national donc faux cette solution pseudo
juridique purement juridique sur un
problème qui est un problème je dirais
d'ordre physique matérielle elle répond
qu'un certain cas très particuliers et
des pl clp le problème en le renvoyant
dans notre pays je suis pas sûr que ça
améliore forcément notre chance de
sécurité pourra de sûreté pour nos
citoyens donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment pas se penser un peu au delà de
cette mesure un peu symbolique qui a
lequel la facilité de désister mais il
faut penser à peu près des choses à plus
long terme là dedans il faut pas tomber
dans la facilité effectivement je suis
tout à fait d'accord d'abord il ya quand
même un droit international qui est
respectée je crois par tous les pays du
monde quand vous avez quelqu'un qui a
une seule nationalité vous ne pouvez pas
le déchoir de sa nationalité parce qu'il
devient par natural apatrides ouais et
donc vous êtes obligé de le garder sous
votre nationalité c'est interdit par les
traités internationaux et je répète tous
les pays le respecte et donc il faut
quand même qu'on ait une réflexion plus
- moins caricaturale que ça parce que
c'est facile de dire et c'est impossible
à faire donc il faut pas non plus
décevoir les gens sur les capacités que
nous avons en revanche que nous
puissions judiciairement traiter des
gens qui vont sur un territoire quand
bien même ce n'est pas le nôtre pour
aller commettre les actes qu on a encore
vu hier sur un pilote jordanien c'est à
dire qu'on puisse les traduire par
exemple devant je fais une succès chez
d'une suggestion devant un tribunal
pénal international pour crimes contre
l'humanité ou autre oui ça c'est
peut-être envisageable c'est à dire
qu'ils ne passent pas parce que le
problème c'est qu'ils vont commettre des
crimes affreux en irak en syrie on sait
comment procède des chaussées comparses
et quand ils reviennent en france on est
on est con on les condamne pourquoi pour
rien or ils ont commis sans doute des
actes et peut-être qu'il y aura un
système judiciaire international qui
pourrait traiter l'ensemble de ces
islamistes qui grattent donc ça sera à
l'international ce serait peut-être une
réflexion à la consommation répond
judiciaire à des gens quand on sait
qu'ils ont fait des actes dans sa touche
tous les pays puisqu'il ya c'était un
pilote jordanien avant-hier c'était un
japonais
et c'est donc effectivement ça tout
juste sa seule réponse des circonstances
très particulières sur lesquels ce qui
se passe en scène ne devrait pas voir ne
rentre pas forcément dans le cadre de la
justice on a quand même des outils
juridiques hyper deux autres étaient ces
gens là on à l'association 2 mains de
terroristes dans le but l'organisation
de la session dans une organisation dans
un but à visée terroriste
donc on a certain type de méthode dans
le pays qui existent pour pouvoir
traiter ces individus du point de vue
juridique
je pense que la vraie question c'est
comment les attraper avant qu'il ne
repasse à l'acte sur le territoire c'est
la réponse juridique attendant un second
temps on a vraiment une réponse matière
dans un premier temps qui et comment
mais en moi en place les moyens comment
on passe au delà de cette protection
parce que aujourd'hui on va diminuer aux
mille militaires sont déployés sur le
sol national
c'est bien c'est une très bonne chose je
ne nie pas à la question c'est qu'on va
faire après parce qu'on peut laisser six
mois 12 mois 18 mois au bout d'un moment
on va arrêter de les mettre
la jordanie a réfléchi moins longtemps
on a tué leurs pilotes ce matin à 4
heures du matin ils ont tué deux
djihadistes qui étaient condamnés à mort
effectivement beaucoup de gens se
demandent s'il faut pas une extrême
rigueur face à des gens qui n'ont pas
d'états d'âme
qu'est ce que je pense sur la réponse de
la démocratie ça peut pas être la loi du
talion
je pense qu'on défend chez la démocratie
en défendant cette conception même si
elle est difficile à entendre je
reconnais qu'elle est difficile à
entendre
la jordanie à la peine de mort donc très
bien mais cette espèce de réaction
permanente de dire tu me touches je te
tue moi je suis très sceptique sur cette
cette façon d'opérer
on peut pas rentrer dans ce cycle de
violence où on perd nos valeurs et
sélectionnant c'est ce que veulent le
faire passer le terrorisme nous fait
rentrer en ce cycle pour qu'on y perd
nous mêmes notre âme quelque part entre
amené aux critiques et nos valeurs qu'on
m'impose des lois très très restrictive
sur les libertés et au final courant
dans une confrontation absolue sur leur
terrain à eux quand ils veulent nous
apporte nous amener sur le terrain
je pense qu'il faut fonction pas rentrer
là dedans il ya des moyens qui peuvent
être très ferme on a d'autres
possibilités très ferme au delà bien
avant la peine de mort faut aussi
réfléchir là dessus
alors parlons maintenant du deuxième
tour de la législative partielle dans le
doubs dimanche prochain
ni soutien au front national ni soutien
au ps a décidé le bureau politique de
l'ump hier soir contrairement à la
position de nicolas sarkozy
c'est clairement un désaveu pour le
président de l'ump marc fesneau je sais
pas s'il faut le poser dans ces termes
là parce que la question c'est pas le
désaveu les questions c'est là ce qui
est sorti du bureau politique
manifestement il ya eu un débat c'est un
fait ou le sérieux ou c'est la limite
tant mieux qu'il y ait un débat s'est
salués poussé le score est assez serré
puisque ces 19 voix contre 22 c'est
plutôt ça qui m'interpelle que de savoir
parce qu'effectivement les
éditorialistes depuis ce matin 10
nicolas sarkozy n'a plus prise sur son
parti n'est plus chef de son parti
bon ça c'est les affaires internes de
l'ump ce qui est important c'est la
parole de l'ump sur cette affaire du
front national d'accord mais il avait
une position et le bureau politique n'a
pas pris la même oui enfin il a si j'ai
bien compris il a mis deux propositions
sur la table et lui-même s'est abstenu
il n'a pas pris part au vote
même s'il avait manifestement
effectivement évolué et pris une
position plus intermédiaire en disant
jamais le front national et après vous
avez le choix
bon ça c'est vrai que pour lui peut-être
c'est une affaire mais c'est une
querelle au sein de l'ump qui ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui qui n'a pas été à mon
avis réellement trancher
deuxième élément de réflexion c'est la
position elle même je pense que la
position qui a été prise par un certain
nombre de responsables alain juppé en
tête et tu policiers courageuse parce
que c'est pas forcément facile de dire
ce qu'il a dit compte tenu de la où il
est mais en même temps je crois qu'il
n'y a pas d'autres positions à tenir
deux remarques là dessus quand vous êtes
dans un deuxième tour vous n'êtes pas
présent votre formation politique
et voilà sensibilité vous trop
privilégié n'est pas présent vous êtes
obligé de faire un choix
quand vous êtes dans une élection
présidentielle au premier tour vous
choisissez au deuxième tour vous
éliminez maîtres le signe égal entre
front national est parti socialiste je
trouve c'est être extrêmement danger en
tonnes de le symbole et de valeur parce
que on est nous comme l'ump dans
l'opposition à la politique est menée
par le gouvernement mais enfin sur un
certain nombre de valeurs quand on
l'entend en plus qu'a dit elle même la
candidate parce qu'il faut aussi
regarder les candidats sur la question
de la distinction des races et
d'ailleurs archi entre les races je
pense qu'à un moment on peut pas mettre
un signe égal et donc quand bien même ça
ne fasse pas plaisir on est obligé de
procéder un choix et moi je pensé hier
aux électeurs de gauche qui avaient pas
envie de voter chirac en 2002 et qui
malgré tout sont allés voter chirac sur
l'appel et la sollicitation qui était
bonne d'ailleurs de jacques chirac à
l'époque et de tous ceux qui hier ont
peut-être pris une position différente
je connais des tas de gens au parti
socialiste n'était pas ravi de prendre
cette position ils ont considéré que
dans le choix qui leur étaient données
pouvait pas dire ni parce que si vous
allez
dans ce choix là par exemple on va avoir
des régionales au mois de décembre
théoriquement on aura peut-être marine
le pen candidate dans la région nord pas
de calais picardie on va dire ni ni
entre les deux tours si par malheur
c'était le seul choix qui était proposé
donc il ya quand même une réflexion
moyen terme et long termes à porter qui
me semble-t-il fait défaut aujourd'hui
mais on a le sentiment que le sentiment
de désespérance des français aujourd'hui
a quand même évolué depuis l'époque de
chirac on sent que les français son père
lui ne savent plus à quel saint se vouer
effectivement et si on dit nini c'est
justement parce que c'est bonnet blanc
et blanc bonnet finalement pour beaucoup
de français en fait les français ils ont
dit ni ni ni ils ont dit ni ump au
premier tour et après l' ump du ni fn ni
ps ni front national je pense qu'il fera
que 66 % d'abstention dit ni à la aux
partis politiques parce que ça je
premier est quand même celui ci à
retenir le deuxième point c'est que que
l'ump prenne pas possible près des
positions diverses finalement c'est ça
reflète quelque chose ça au fait que les
électeurs aujourd'hui se sont beaucoup
moins plus beaucoup moins contraint
beaucoup plus libres dans leur choix je
pense que c'est une bonne chose parce
que il ya une sentiment de compétence de
lecteurs par rapport à l'élu qui a
beaucoup changé le rapport d'autorité
qu'il pouvait y avoir n'existe plus ça
aussi il faut bien s'en rendre compte
et l'électeur n'a pas du tout envie de
se dé que consigne de vote et sont
complètement dépassés ont un côté très
suranné aujourd'hui donc je pense que le
fait qu'un parti ait plusieurs et
plusieurs opinions personnelles parce
qu'au final c'est chacun chacun des
ténors politiques qui exprime sa propre
vision son propre choix qu'il aurait
fait dans ces circonstances là le fait
qu'il y en ait qui aidé plusieurs
opinions est plutôt une bonne chose
montrent que le parti a des reflets de
diverses diversité je pense que la
droite doit absolument sortir de ce
petit jeu dans lequel on enferme un peu
leur ai dit ce qui est la guerre des ego
donc l'un contre l'autre l'a perdu du
pouvoir le train de gagner un fait une
erreur stratégique une erreur politique
on tourne en rond avec ça comme ça mais
quand ce vu de l'extérieur ça fait
cacophonie quand même nom mais on se
concentre sur quelque chose alors que la
droite alors l objectif d'être une force
d'opposition à vous de porter un
programme d'opposition au gouvernement
puisqu'elle n'est pas d'accord avec la
politique du gouvernement saad el le
maintien tout à longueur de journée est
là et je pense que elle a plutôt raison
mais elle doit porter un programme elle
doit pas se battre pour savoir s'il faut
donner des consignes de vote aujourd'hui
d'apporter des idées et des idées
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui manque
clairement il faut aussi le dire on
manque pas de personnes les débats sur
les ego et les personnes à bout
les débats sur le programme qui a
apporté ya pas grand chose puisque à
part s'opposer à la loi macron qu'est ce
qui a eu comme proposition ces douze
derniers mois pas grand chose et donc
c'est là où la droite d'aujourd'hui
porter le fer que vous inspire le
commentaire de bruno le maire député ump
qui dit partout sur le terrain c'est le
même message la mayonnaise sarkozy ne
prend pas marc fesneau genevoise experts
que bruno le maire pour répondre à cette
question je suis moins en contact avec
l'électorat ump que lui sans doute en
tout cas j'ai pas le sentiment je pense
que nicolas sarkozy voulait revenir
comme un recours dans son électorat et
plus globalement des échos g parce que
je suis sur le terrain quand même et par
ailleurs je pense que de ce point de vue
là non c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas j'ai
pas si on peut parler de mayonnaise
n'est pas dans des affaires de cuisine
mais je pense que il ya quelque chose
qui n'est pas qu'ils rompu d'une
certaine façon en termes de capacité à
changer et à proposer une offre
politique nouvelle je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose qui est rompu et que donc
c'est toute la difficulté nicolas
sarkozy puis deuxièmement moi je pense
d'ailleurs annoncé plusieurs de ses amis
lui avaient déconseillé le fait qu'il se
soit remis à la tête d'un parti
politique il a vécu hier ce que vivent
tous les présidents de partis politiques
c'est à dire la difficulté à effectuer
des synthèses et essayer de faire
converger des tempéraments et des des
profils différents et juste un mot sur
ce qui vient d'être dit moi je trouve
que dans les partis politiques qui est
un peu de débat c'est pas gênant c'est à
dire qu'il faut quand même vous allez au
parti socialiste il ya des débats dans
tous les partis politiques à des débats
sur les lignes stratégiques sur des
positions idéologiques moi je qu'à
chaque fois on transforme tout débat
comment dirais-je en cacophonie je
trouve ça un peu dommage je pense qu'il
faut il faut respecter le débat à pompe
et en accord ou en désaccord avec les
positions qui sont sortis qu'il y ait
des débats dans les partis politiques
mais évidemment nicolas sarkozy ne nous
avait pas habitué à conduire comme ça le
fait en tout cas c'est le message qu'ils
nous avaient été envoyés depuis un
certain nombre d'années
donc c'est vrai que sur le terrain moi
je ne sens pas en tout cas une volonté
je suis pas sûr que nicolas sarkozy
aurait pour répondre à un besoin de
changement et un besoin d'une autre
offre politique ou d'un rassemblement
qui soit d'une autre nature que celui
qui l'avait opéré en particulier en 2012
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
finalement il ya une désespérance de la
part des français et
ni nicolas sarkozy ni françois hollande
ni personne n'arrive à redonner
confiance aux français qui n'ont pas de
travail qui n'ont pas d'argent qui n'ont
plus de pouvoir d'achat c'est ça la
réalité finalement pour les histoires
politiques aux politiques ça les
intéresse bien sûr aujourd'hui la faut
bien comprendre il faut bien comprendre
que la france est le pays d'europe sur
lequel moins d'appétence à la politique
et le moins intéressé par la chose
politique tout simplement parce que les
politiques ont beaucoup déçu et bon ça
il faut quand même réussir à à dire et à
faire ce diagnostic alors pas tous les
niveaux forcément à l'échelon local on a
une plus grande confiance qui est
exprimée vers les éleveurs envers les
élus locaux ouverts les élus nationaux
mais aujourd'hui effectivement la
confiance envers l'état l'état en
général et cette politique qui tient
l'état quelque part et quand même assez
définitivement rompu par contre là où je
mets une un bémol c'est que la confiance
entre les individus restent très fortes
et on le voit avec l'ample la marche du
1 janvier il ya une très forte cohésion
d'individuels entre les ânes des
individus des français entre eux c'est
envers les populations plus forte on a
l'impression que les français sont
tellement bas qu'ils sont prêt à serrer
les coudes et à créer une grande
alliance
et puis les l'être humain est fait idéal
donc l'être humain rêve d'idéal et cette
idée là on a l'impression que les
politiques ne n'arrive pas à le saisir
et puis à le proposer aux français même
si lyon en janvier est exceptionnel
quand même mais le web social mais on le
voit tous les jours dans le renouveau de
la vie associative le renouveau de des
brocantes vous avez quelque chose qui a
comblé la cause de l'économie
collaborative dans ce mot nouveau qu'on
a mis sur des phénomènes d'anciens par
exemple l'explosion des gros comme dans
les dents les dans les villes et d'aller
les villages c'est quelque chose qui
existe qui est très forte et une très
forte solidarité une très forte cohésion
et comme je lis dans le couple état
nation la nation va plutôt bien c'est
l'état qui va très mal et donc la
confiance entre les individus est plutôt
bonne a confiance envers les autorités
étatiques est très très faible
je pense qu'il ya une volonté des gens
pour rebondir là dessus de trouver du
collectif ils recherchent du collectif
ont valeur vous dites et puis d'autres
parce qu'il ya de plus en plus
d'isolement dans l'impression que déjà
les gens les employeurs ne veulent plus
employé donc beaucoup d'auto
entrepreneur beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent dans leur coin qui essayent
2 et boye et c'est donc c'est ça
peut-être qui créé il ya un mal qu il ya
un appel au collectif un appel un projet
qui soit un peu ambitieux et qu'ils
soient pas simplement la somme des
individualités et pour le coup les
partis politiques ne savent pas répondre
à ce que les partis politiques y sont
encore
aujourd'hui dans le débat majorité
opposition droite gauche
et tant qu'on n'arrivera pas à sortir et
à ceux des passionnés de ce débat là
pour dire oui droite gauche ok
opposition majorité ok parce qu'il en
faut dans une démocratie mais en même
temps quels sont les grands caps qu'on
peut se donner quelles sont les grandes
lignes directrices qu'on peut se donner
est ce que là ya pas moyen de rassembler
un certain nombre de français qui
auraient envie d'aller dans la même
direction
tant qu'on sera dans cette logique là
moi je pense sur la circonscription du
doubs dont on parle il ya deux minutes
l'essentiel de la campagne du candidat
ump était dire il faut qu il lui faut
pas que le parti socialiste il faut
qu'ils perdent la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale ça peut pas être un projet
politique
comprenez ça n'a pas parlé aux électeurs
de la majorité bon an mal an et 1 et
cyril vous disiez ça n'a pas parlé aux
aux électeurs de la série d'inspections
s'interroger c'est le seul projet peut
pas être de dire je bats celui qui m'a
battue ça peut pas être à une alternance
succès d'une alternance l'objectif c'est
pas l'alternance l'objectif c'est le
projet c'est pourquoi l'alternance à
quoi ça sert les escomptes des français
il n'y a pas cet idéal là il n'y a pas
de vision n'y a pas là la chose numéro 1
h f c'est quoi c'est d'avoir une vision
donne un cap de donner un cap c'est le
patron c'est le capitaine du patient les
gens cherchent et on n'a personne pour
donner un cap c'est je vais prendre ta
place je vais gagner je vais ma charge
et alain coup c'est moi et 66 %
d'abstention parce que les français ne
se retrouve pas non plus un puisque en
fait vous avez vous propres ont jamais
les jeunes inscrits dont les
abstentionnistes donc compter qu'à 10%
des inscrits dans ce pays vous arrivez à
76 voir les chiffres sont quand même
assez énorme avec en plus des disparités
selon les classes d'âge les jeunes vous
avez des taux encore qu'ils sont deux
fois plus faible que chez les plus de 65
ans donc il ya des disparités très fort
et c'est très mauvais signe sur cette
absence de vitalité démocratique trouve
beaucoup sont ces causes quand même
c'est pas que les gens ne veulent pas
voter c'est qu'ils nous jouent
aujourd'hui il ne trouve pas l'offre
politique qu'il souhaiterait en face
d'eux effectivement en fait on attend
notre sauveur on attend le héros qui va
venir donner ce cas peut-être un nouveau
de gaulle je crois ni aux hommes n'y ait
ni homme ni femme providentielle puisque
héros ou zéro avec un héroïne
mais je pense que le changement viendra
de l'intérieur il y aura au fort c'est
aujourd'hui forcément il y aura un
politique qui a fini par se rendre
compte que qui en proposant une vision
qui va gagner en proposant cette vision
parce que les gens sont très demandeurs
et donc ça va venir de l'intérieur je le
pense vraiment marc fesneau robin gibb
et on s'arrête quelques instants un peu
de pub et puis le face-à-face revient
après la pub a tout de suite les 12-14
info sud radio
le face à face des éditorialistes avec
nous aujourd'hui marc fesneau secrétaire
général du modem et l'économiste robin
rivaton pour commenter l'actualité dans
le face à face des éditorialistes de sud
radio parlons maintenant de cette
pastille verte qui va faire son retour
avant l'été annonce de ségolène royal
cette prime de 10000 euros avant l'été
également pour l'achat d'un véhicule
électrique en cas de remplacement d'un
véhicule diesel la transition
énergétique on y est ça va devenir enfin
concret pour les français marc fesneau
si vous croyez qu'une pastille verte et
10000 euros sur une voiture électrique
ça va être une politique énergétique est
optimiste j'attends la suite des mesures
pour tout vous dire c'est ségolène royal
qui le dira c'est facile mais brioude et
si la belle non mais c'était pas vous
évidemment d'abord la pastille verte
l'éternel retour il ya dix ans ou 12 ans
on avait déjà inventé la pastille verte
bon 80 kg alors qui a capoté en 2003 oui
c'est ce que je dis ouais et 12 ans nous
avait dit on va faire une pastille verte
et après on sélectionnera les voitures à
l'entrée dans les jours de pollution
enfin moi je crois que d'abord on est
sur du coercitif quand même au bout
parce que c'est angie c'est pour mettre
en valeur les véhicules les moins
polluants ou montfort au final c'est
pour interdire aux véhicules les plus
polluants de rentrer dans les vides
alors d'abord sur les phénomènes de
transition énergétique puis là on
mélange la pollution les particules et
les problèmes de transition énergétique
qui sont pas tout à fait les problèmes
de même nature
il ya une transition opérée en
particulier sont toutes une transition
opérée sur le diesel
alors après avoir donné un grand coup de
volant pour le diesel on est en train de
donner un autre coup de volant contre le
dz tout ça est très bien mais des fois
qu'on a un peu de continuité dans la
politique publique ce serait pas mal
deuxième chose je pense qu'il ya des
mesures d'accompagnement mais il faut
vous mettre sous m face à la réalité
déjà on en parlait tout à l'heure c'est
dire que les gens ils sont comme dans
des situations de précarité y compris de
précarité économique qui font que la
prime de 10000 euros quand vous avez un
surcoût comme celui du véhicule écrit je
suis pas sûr que ça soit très incitatif
donc on est plutôt sur les affaires de
circulation des voitures sur des
politiques de long terme on peut pas
dire qu'on n'est pas avancer dans les
villes on peut pas dire qu'on n'est pas
réduit quand même la présence de la
voiture alors évidemment il ya des
sceaux peut être affaire me semble-t-il
mais quand même
deuxième chose je pense qu'il ya un
sujet majeur si on est sur la transition
énergétique c'est dessus le sujet
d'économie d'énergie parce que ça a un
intérêt écologique
c'est un intérêt environnemental et
c'est un intérêt économique dire que
vous irez vous vous y retrouver
c'est à dire que l'investissement que
fait le particulier où l'entreprise ou
autres pour améliorer sa performance
énergétique ou faire évoluer son système
de chauffage
il retrouve son investissement dans les
années qui suivent est donc là on a un
intérêt de long terme sans compter mais
mon voisin on parlera beaucoup mieux que
moi les effets induits en termes de
développement économique et de finir
qu'on peut développer donc c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut axer pour qu'on ait
des champions aussi dans ce domaine là
l'autre jour j'étais dans un tout petit
village dans mon département avec un
point un grand prestataire chinois qui
arrivent
venant avec une envie passer débordante
de prendre des marchés en termes
d'économies d'énergie en particulier sur
l'éclairage public c'est quand même pas
possible on a des grands opérateurs
france il faut qu'on arrive nous avoir
une politique suffisamment évidentes et
suffisamment lisible pour que des grands
opérateurs puissent réellement avoir une
politique industrielle claire là dessus
quand je vois les les revirements qu'on
a eu par exemple sur le solaire les
revirements qu'on a vu sur l'éolien en
permanence on donne des coups de volant
à droite et à gauche presque
politiquement d'une certaine façon pour
faire en sorte qu'on ait pas de filière
les allemands ont des filières
énergétiques puissante et on a besoin de
monter ces figures là parce que c'est
avec des filières économiques fortes
qu'on arrivera aussi à mener cette
transition énergétique
alors robert 1 re marie vaton justement
pour revenir aux voitures on sait que
les français changent de voiture en
moyenne tous les huit ans est ce que il
serait pas plus intelligents et moins
coercitif d'agir sur les fabricants de
voitures puisque si on change de voiture
en moyenne tous les huit ans ça veut
dire que dans huit ans le parc
automobile sera renouvelée avec des
voitures propres
bien sûr effectivement le problème de
de l'automobile c'est qu'en fait en
manque clairement de cohérence on a une
politique économique qui a été de
favoriser les voitures au diesel du fait
du soutien à la filière automobile
française qui est largement équipés en
diesel donc la france est aujourd'hui
l'un des pays européens aux pays au
monde avec le plus fort taux de
véhicules diesel dans son parc
automobile avec avec l'espagne également
donc la question c'est est ce que
maintenant on va aller à l'encontre de
ce soutien économique alors même que le
gouvernement investit dans un décompte
des deux constructeurs automobiles
nationaux en l'occurrence à psa c'est un
peu difficile a encore une fois on
essaye de on a des politiques
écologiques pour le pot qui sont non
cohérente et qui sont pas suivies sur la
durée et donc on mélange un peu tout là
où en plus la ministre je pense que l
finir c'est vrai qu'elle mélange à la
fois ce qui est à la source de l'énergie
et d'où vient l'énergie alors si on veut
développer un parc elle est en parc de
voitures électriques
on sait qu'il faut développer plus de
centrales nucléaires derrière parce que
c'est le moyen de répondre à la fois la
cour est la surconsommation
d'électricité qu'un qu'induit un parc de
voitures électriques
donc il faut pas tout mélanger et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui le vrai problème
c'est qu'on n'a pas débuté
on n'a pas d'indicateur à long terme or
ceux des politiques qui sont à 20 ans 30
ans plusieurs décennies voire un demi
siècle
on voit bien que les escales foot ce
qu'ont fait les allemands bon ça a été
le même gouvernants mais ça a été suivie
en dépit des coalitions des alliances
avec les écolos des alliances avec les
socialistes
il n'y a pas eu de remise en cause de
cette des objectifs qui ont été fixés et
une vraie prouesse est manque de
cohérence qui est un vrai gros sujets
qui nous pose problème et surtout cette
ambivalence du gouvernement qui arrive
pas du gouvernement mais pas de souci
que de celui-ci en l'occurrence mais qui
n'arrivent pas à trancher entre des
choix écologiques très fort qui se
feront au détriment de l'économie parce
qu'il ya une loi et quand des choix
écologiques sont fait ça perturbe
l'organisation économique telle qu'elle
a été dessinée il ya quelques années et
donc forcément ça va un effet récessif
ça va être forcé à licencier des
salariés de l'industrie automobile est
ce que c'est ce qu'on veut quel
arbitrage voici le faire et là
aujourd'hui on ne sent pas l'arbitrage
en cachant eh ben on a on essaie de
louvoyer entre les deux on arrive
évidemment pas une position très stable
on voit quand même un changement de
comportement des français en janvier
moins de six voitures neuves sur 10
vendus et et diesel c'est du jamais vu
depuis quinze ans qu'on est vendu aussi
peu de voitures diesel c'est quoi ça une
prise de conscience des français où
justement il se disant là va peut-être
que le diesel sera interdit un jour moi
je
leur est pas en diesel je pourrais
continuer à rouler tout à fait mais
c'est justement c'est ça c'est la bonne
politique c'est la théorie des
incitations c'est à dire qu'on envoie
des signaux aux gens en leur disant ben
voilà on remonte progressivement le
diesel on va essayer d'aligner les taxes
sur entre l'essence et le diesel
à long terme on va plus taxes et le
diesel les moteurs essence on fait aussi
des progrès dans l'intervalle il ya la
technologie vient aussi au secours du de
l'essence est donc ce qui se passe c'est
que ben les gens changent leurs
comportements petit à petit et c'est ça
la vraie la vraie écologie elle est là
aussi c'est à dire que il faut qu'elles
viennent des gens eux mêmes qu'ils
n'aient pas l'impression d'avoir été
qu'on l'aurait forcé la main qu'on n'ait
pas l'impression de l'avoir donné
beaucoup de subventions parce que l'on
sait que quand on donne beaucoup de
subventions dans un domaine
saadi génère des effets d'opportunités
et qu'à la fin ça se traduit par des
pertes économiques sèche on le simple et
exempte de l'éolienne dans un pays où il
ya peu de vent comme la france c'est une
hérésie
on peut développer une filière solaire
dans le pays mettent des éoliennes dans
un pays où on est mais désolé de
danemark on n'est pas les éoliennes en
france c'est totalement illogique iron
les régions il ya beaucoup de voix - 2
voies en france en tout cas au global
comme beaucoup d'allemandes du nord que
des pays de bien on peut faire du
solaire d'autres pays bref donc il ya
des choix qui n'ont pas été fait des
choix qui sont souvent guidés par une
augmentation politique est finie c'est
qu'ils finissent eux peut au final par
par déstabiliser les français qui
prennent pas leur choix individuels
robin wright ont marqué nos nouvelle
pause dans le 12 14 info side radio et
on revient dans quelques instants les
12-14 info sud radio
le face à face des éditorialistes avec
nous aujourd'hui l'économiste robert et
va-t-on marc fesneau secrétaire général
du modem on va parler sur sud radio
maintenant de la tournée européenne
d'alex ici presse le nouveau premier
ministre grec qui rencontre françois
hollande aujourd'hui
êtes vous confiant robin rivaton d'onces
à sa capacité de conviction pour alléger
la dette grecque
alors moi il m'a fait très peur pendant
la première semaine d'une part parce
qu'il a surpris beaucoup de monde
on savait qu'on allait s'engager dans un
bras de fer entre
avec les autorités européennes mais ils
allés très loin dans la négociation très
très rapidement donc il a choisi déjà de
s'allier avec un parti qui ne manque pas
de susciter la controverse sa partie
plutôt de droite nationaliste c'est
qu'il ya des positions qui sont pas
toujours très claires et évidentes
d'autre part il a fait des menaces de
sortie de l'euro des menaces
d'annulation de la dette de défaut de la
deûle de la dette
il a hissé dit qu'il était prêt à leur
entrée au bras de fer très très loin
donc il a suscité beaucoup d'inquiétude
très rapidement les on a vu les bourses
les valeurs bancaires en grèce ont très
fortement chuté il ya une augmentation
des dépôts des épargnants
donc je pense qu'il a très mal joué sept
cette première semaine aujourd'hui il ya
un message d'apaisement qui est quand
même en redescendu on voit que des
négociations beaucoup plus que calme qui
sont qui sont arrivés et ce qui va
parvenir à ces objectifs tant on
obtiendra un accord c'est sur la
finalité c'est de tenir la corde
personne n'a intérêt à ce que quelqu un
gars qu'est ce que quiconque renverse à
table et encore moins les grecs puisque
les grecs ne veulent pas sortir de
l'euro et je pense qu'aujourd'hui pour
eux ce n'est pas forcément là la
meilleure solution de sortir donc on va
arriver à un accord
il fait son tour sa tournée des
capitales on va voir au fur et à mesure
de cette tournée il va essayer d'aboutir
à une position qui sera la position
finale pour arriver là plus la plus
proche des positions finales en
allemagne à berlin auprès de la
chancelière merkel qui est quand même
l'opposant le plus dur en fait à cette
renégociation delà de la dette
on va arriver on va arriver à quelque
chose mais c'est étrange en tout cas
cette première semaine où il a été très
perturbant marc fesneau
je partage qui vient d'être dit drôle de
semaine de démarrage
y compris pour l'économie grecque
d'ailleurs parce que les messages
étaient un peu compliqués on a deux sur
une chose dont le sujet me semble-t-il
il ya la dette passée partir du postulat
que nous effacerons la dette c'est de
nous envoyer un message on parlait de
messages tout à l'heure un message
politique économique qui serait mon avis
désastreux qu'on puisse poser les
conditions du rééchelonnement de la
dette pour c'est vrai que la grèce a
pris beaucoup alors il y avait une
responsabilité des gouvernants grecs 1
depuis des dizaines d'années d'incurie
budgétaire encore que les français et
pas forcément des le de leçon à donner
mais nous n'étions pas dans ce set
étiages là du tout
que la grèce ait besoin de faire des
efforts mais c'est vrai que les efforts
qui ont été demandés aux grecs sont des
efforts extrêmement violent et on ne
mesure pas à quel point la leaf et
d'austérité a été très violent chez eux
avec un effet récessif qui a quand même
était assez fort donc l'idée de
rééchelonner la grève là la dette par
mon grecque est une bonne idée mais de
toute façon deux gouvernements s'y
pressent silva to believe est face à une
autre difficulté c'est qu'il a besoin
d'argent aujourd'hui
et donc s'il commence à dire partout qui
remboursera pas sa tête qui va lui
prêter
c'est à dire que c'est facile de tenir
un discours sur le thème de j'efface la
dette je paierai plus alors ça c'est
pour le passé on est content on paie
plus adepte puis quand l'avenir arriver
que vous avez besoin tous les jours de
centaines de millions ou 2 milliards
d'euros et sur le marché on vous dit
mais monsieur je vous ai déjà prêté de
l'argent vous ne l'avez pas remboursés
donc il sera bien obligé d'aller au
compromis même si là il a fallu qu'ils
envoient des messages parce que c'est le
malheur des campagnes électorales c'est
que parfois on va un peu loin dans les
propositions pour gagner un électorat
facilement ça nous enseigne aussi que
tous ceux qui font dans des oeuvres de
populisme et démagogie ce moment il faut
se retrouver face à la table et donc
qu'il va être obligé de face à cette
réalité là de renégocier mais qu'on
renégocie je trouve que le message
serait pas indécent vis à vis des grecs
et qu'on arrête de leur renvoyer en
permanence à la figure qui font pas
assez d'efforts qu'il faut aller plus
loin parce qu'ils ont fait beaucoup ils
ont fait qu énormément d'efforts
effectivement quel rôle peut jouer
françois hollande justement dans alors
d'un côté la grèce qui veut alléger sa
dette de l'autre côté angela merkel qui
qui apparaît intraitable faut lui donner
un rôle de trait d'union à la france
serait peut-être un peu présomptueux
puisque finale quand même les allemands
ont quand même une bonne partie du
destin de la grèce et de la zone euro et
de l'union européenne entre leurs mains
aujourd'hui donc on arrivera une
position qui sont qui sera quand même
très proche de la leur donc croire que
la france aura une capacité d'influencé
aujourd'hui se berner un peu surtout vu
j'ai vu la propre le propre état de
notre de nos finances publiques un nom
qu'on serait mal placé pour donner des
leçons
on peut essayer de jouer plus ou moins
en disant qu'on soutient un peu cette
renégociation mais on aura un impact à
la marge
moi ce qui m'intéresse quand à voir
c'est que la semaine dernière dimanche
dernier tout le monde était grec ya tous
les partis ont célébré la victoire de
sipera c'était quand même assez
impression d'avoir un tel consensus
politique ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu aujourd'hui quand même on
se rend compte effectivement que la la
bulle de populisme plus ou moins éclatée
et qu' il ya plein grand monde qui est
capable de qui est aujourd'hui je crois
qu'il ya le front national qui a dit
qu'il fallait quand même
y remboursera ben oui on l'espère bien
et c'était pas la peine dans ce cas là
les soutenir mordicus mordicus à un
candidat qui a annoncé qu'il ne le
ferait pas donc c'est aussi bien de
montrer que tous les populistes qui en
ont beaucoup profité aujourd'hui se
retrouve quand même un peu la tête dans
le caniveau à moins faire les malins
quand il s'agit de dire concrètement
grec qu'il faut en bourse cela dit on a
déjà vu des dettes annulées
on a déjà c'est possible alors ça c'est
déjà fait ça se fait régulièrement ça
s'appelle le club de paris sa serais
venu à paris en plus donc les grands
créanciers mondiaux de temps en temps
vont annuler la dette de pays c'est
notamment des pays qui sont proches des
pays qui sont les moins ce qu'on appelle
les paie les anciens pma les pays les
moins avancés dont qui ont des graves
problèmes sociaux bien pire que la grèce
la grèce pour le coup et c'est des pays
dans lequel la dette a sert normalement
a servi à quelque chose
le problème de la grèce et qu'elle s'est
endettée pendant de 2000 notamment des
82 fin 95 à 2010 de manière à augmenter
son niveau de vie de manière
artificielle donc on peut dire qu'il ya
une austérité on peut dire ce qu'on veut
ça c'est sûr qu'il ya eu de s'arrêter ça
sans doute été très dur mais pendant 15
ans les grecs se sont endettés pour
augmenter artificiellement le niveau de
vie et c'est une très mauvaise chose et
il est nécessaire que c'est ce que ces
comportements là ne soit pas tolérer
faut qu'on comprenne bien c'est comme si
un particulier prenez des crédits
revolving des crédits à la consommation
nations les années pendant pouvoir aller
en vacances s'acheter des vêtements d'un
moment soit le banquier vous ferme le
crédit et le robinet soit et vous dis il
faut rembourser mais très rapidement
vous met sous tutelle
voilà où on les a mis sous on les a mis
sous tutelle d'une certaine manière
aussi mais à un moment il faut
rembourser
sinon qu'est ce qui se passe c'est que
le veau de voisins qui est en
l'occurrence le portugal l'espagne ou
l'irlande demandera que le même
traitement de faveur du soir
souhaiterait il n'y a pas de raison
qu'il ne le soit qu'il soit fait pour un
pays pas pour les autres donc il faut
être très prudent sur l'idée qu' on
effacerait tous que ça c'est déjà fait
oui ça c'est déjà fait mais ça coûtera
750 euros par français je pense pas
personnellement que je aujourd'hui
l'association opus permettra donc voilà
il faut être quand même très clair en
tout cas merci infiniment marc fesneau
donc je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du modem et merci à
robin rivaton économistes essayiste et
auteur